stories are the help of CIA the same way
they got rid of the show with the help
of CI and you know Kissinger and Carter
the same Playbook they used with mozader
well a little more aggressive they
actually uh so put him in a village and
just the the the most of that Revolution
was in 1953 uh where once again the
Iranians rose up kicked the Shah out of
the country this is the third time we
we've done this but not not the young
shot the the father as a Khan you're
talking about no no this was this is
Muhammad Raza pallavi yeah 53 that's
right that's right 50th Muhammad yeah
the same shot that left in 79. uh we
threw him out and replaced him with this
nationalist government at the head was
the Prime Minister Mohammed mosadek uh
had very radical sort of democratic
nationalistic ideas one of which was to
nationalize Iran's oil like why are we
why are we giving away our oil to the
British uh you know in exchange for rent
like literally that's what it was in
exchange for like they rent the the the
land and then extract the oil and keep
it
um and so we nationalized the oil uh the
British were obviously devastated by
that move but this was post-world War II
and the British were just this powerless
Island now you know that the empire was
gone
so they asked their good friends The
Americans
for help and this was when the CIA had
first been created uh it came from the
OSS from World War II but now the war is
gone so now we have this intelligence
apparatus what do we do with this until
we nobody had any idea what to do with
the CIA until a very clever clever uh
agent by the name of Kermit Roosevelt
um that I believe grandson of Teddy
Roosevelt I think or grand nephew of
Teddy Roosevelt came up with this great
idea and it was hey why don't we uh put
the shaw back on the throne I can do
that give me four guys in a suitcase
with a hundred thousand dollars in it
and that as absurd and as like Ocean's
11 as that sounds economic Hitman it's
just that was it there were like four
guys it was a boxer uh a Communications
nerd I mean why isn't this a movie
Kermit Roosevelt who's like this 97
pound coke bottle glasses wearing nerd
uh he looks like Joe Montana and a
couple of other people and uh what a
mustache no does he not look like Joe
Montana he's like an elderly Joe Montana
a little bit right there yeah and uh and
it took them a couple of months and they
went to Iran in a couple of months they
created a fake counter protest removed
mosodeg from power and put the Shah back
on the throne and the British said thank
you very much we'll take the oil back
now and the Americans said no
no yeah we did all the work I think
we're just gonna stay and that was the
birth of the problematic relationship
between the U.S and Iran that then LED
in 79 to the anti-American Revolution do
you know the the 25-year contract
between that do you know the story about
the 25-year contract okay can you pull
up the 1954 oil Iran contract just type
that in it'll come up this is so
interesting with everything you're
saying where all the timing is now
making sense there you go the Consortium
agreement of 1954 zoom in a little bit
for us to read this they signed a
25-year contract
so the concern of government 1915 will
provide a western companies with 50
owners should be running an old
production after its ratification in
1954-79 despite the numerous
negotiations and offers the shav Iran
refused to extend agreement which
originally and clearly postulated that
the Consortium he had had the right to
prolong at least 15 years three times
five years anyways this thing is
expiring in 1979. so check this out 53
54 they signed a contract 25 years the
ownership I think is through with France
I want to say Obviously UK us and
there's one other country in that I
don't know if it's Germany or Dutch
Shell the Oriole Dutch Shell yeah so
they team it and then there's a meeting
which by the way this would be a very
interesting documentary to watch I
watched this I couldn't believe it there
was a meeting in in the South or Central
America by four uh leaders in 1978 or 77
deciding on how to make the shop about
fall
and because they knew the show
specifically kept saying I'm increasing
prices I'm increasing prices once this
expires obviously they don't want him to
have that kind of power boom with the
help of that the next economic Hitman
comes in we got to replace the shop
Iran's been used by uh people of the
West for many many years so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]